many people ask me questions about stoic
philosophy
and practice i've created this series to
provide short answers to the most common
recurring or confusing questions about
stoicism
one common question that arises when it
comes to stoicism
is what are the first steps to becoming
stoic and so there's a lot to say in
response to this
excellent question i think it's
excellent in that it gives us a lot of
opportunities to explore some things
that need to
to be examined and it also
represents a sort of diligence
and wish to improve oneself using
something that perhaps one doesn't know
that much about
so the answers that i'm going to provide
here
some of them are positive you definitely
want to do these sorts of things
some of them are negative meaning that
i'm saying ah you probably want to avoid
this because
it's actually going to be a distraction
or it's going to be too superficial
or it's going to take you off the path
and set you behind
in some respects and i will say right
off the bat that
what i'm saying here these are my views
about it and there
there are some other experts on stoicism
who probably
would disagree with at least some of
this and that's that's perhaps a good
starting point there is no one single
stoic path and there is no one single
thing that you
absolutely have to begin with whether
it's a concept or a practice
or some sort of arrangement of things
like the three disciplines
you can approach stoicism think of it as
a building
that is you know vast in in its scope
and it has a number of different doors
you're not going to necessarily get
everything by going in one
door but you're not going to ruin
yourself
either by going in this door rather than
that door so
all that said by by way of preamble
let's break it down i would say that
there's there's three main
areas that you want to focus on
one of these is understanding what
stoicism is so
that's pretty important you know how are
you going to become
stoic whatever that means unless you
actually know
what stoicism stands for and and means
so there's no getting around that
another
really vital dimension i would say and
this is
this holds not just for stoicism but for
virtue ethics and philosophies
as ways of life in general practice
practice practice practice in the sense
of repeating it
and let's say practice in the plural
there are many different stoic practices
and you're going to want to start doing
some of them but not all of them as
we're going to explain
and then we can also talk about
direction orientation
motivation as being something important
as well
and there's there's a learning process
that takes place so let's talk about
understanding first now again
much that could be said about that i'm
going to try to condense this a little
bit
to understand what stoicism is so that
you have some
idea of what you're shooting at you
probably want to get rid of
any sort of preconceived notions that
you're bringing to it
as baggage so if you're associating
stoicism with
the stiff upper lip and not showing
emotion that's actually
wrong when it comes to classic stoicism
stoicism as a philosophy you want to get
rid of that
you want to if you can't get it out of
your mind at least as we say
put it in brackets right you have to be
open to learning what stoicism is
you want to actually i would say go to
the primary sources
we're fortunate in that we do have some
of the writings of the classical stoics
and they're available in a number of
translations some of them are more
old-fashioned some of them are more
contemporary
and more readable every one of you
who is watching this video you can in
fact
read seneca you can in fact read marcus
aurelius
you can in fact read epictetus those are
the big three
and you really do want to begin by
at least spending some time reading at
least a bit
of their work i always suggest beginning
with epictetus and caridian
and maybe marcus aurelius's meditations
and then going into the seneca and then
going back to the epictetus and then
reading other things as well but if you
just start with those
that can be quite helpful there's also
resources available
all over the internet to help you
understand these things
you know free courses videos podcasts
all that that sort of stuff and there's
nothing wrong with
using those sorts of resources but you
do want to spend some time
with the original text so that you're
getting it from the source
that doesn't mean that you can't read
you know things that are about stoicism
and are presenting it in in digested
form
or perhaps a more popular form
for you but you always have to be
careful it's sort of like
relying on somebody else there's a lot
of
let's just call it mediocre and
superficial
material out there on stoicism some of
it actually gets things wrong
and so you're not going to know who's
getting things right
unless you know who's reliable and the
index for reliability is of course
accordance with the the primary
teachings
and text so there are some you know good
secondary
sources out there but you've got to be a
bit careful so don't place
too much reliance on that i would say
anything that presents stoicism
as a life hack or you know the 10 easy
steps for stoicism
you want to be a bit leery of that sort
of stuff or
they're saying that all these different
historical figures are stoic
who aren't really affiliated with
stoicism
take that with the proverbial grain of
salt
i would say that you also want to if you
can
find a community to join in in there can
be virtual communities
like the various facebook groups that
are out there and
you know some of the people in those
groups are going to be at different
levels of expertise but you can find
some some decent stuff
in there you got to be careful about the
as i you know the sort of superficial
life hack stoicism
but you can find some really good
resources as well there are local
stoic communities that you can join in
and you can
you know bounce ideas off of other
people ask questions
many of them are available virtually due
to cobid19
and there's other things you can do you
can find somebody who's more experienced
to be kind of a coach or a guide for for
those sorts of things you can take
online
classes there are a number of them
available so all of that will help you
with
understanding what stoicism is
and then you can decide whether you
really want to be a stoic
or not second thing practice practice
is extraordinarily important because
this is not a theoretical philosophy
just by itself
practice is integral to stoicism and
practice and theory
have to be integrated within stoicism
and that's part of how you actually
learn
there are a lot of stoic practices out
there
i would suggest starting with one or two
not trying to as we say boil the ocean
just pick
one or two to actually play around with
on a daily basis
you might pick out a particular time of
day to work on say negative
visualization
or you might think about how you apply
them in actual
situations so when we do the practice of
you know taking a pause
and examining impressions that are
coming in or any of the other stoic
practices
there's the working on them like
rehearsal
and then there's the trying to actually
pull it off
and do it in real life situations and we
could find something kind of in between
as well we could do role playing or
stuff like that but you should you
should experiment with these practices
because
stoicism is a practical
philosophy and so now why begin with one
or two
because you want to get good at it right
if you're trying to learn an instrument
you don't try to do every single drill
and master every single technique all at
once
you go along kind of plotting bit by bit
by bit by bit and by the way this is
great
advice for any spiritual path
any intentional way of living any
philosophy of life you're going to see
that sort of you know
advice being given the other thing
that's important with practice
as you're starting out get yourself into
the habit
of paying attention to what you succeed
in
and what you fail in and and why
did you succeed in it because you
actually got it completely right or were
you just lucky
in this situation and you need to work
on it a bit more
did you fail because you didn't follow
through all the way did you fail because
some emotions arose and you allow those
to dominate
instead of rationality did you fail
because you became distracted
did you fail because you actually had
the wrong idea of what you were getting
into
these are all important considerations
the other things that i'll say about
beginning
as a stoic the biggest mistake that i've
seen
in years of talking with people who are
starting out
is expecting that because you have now
committed to this thing that you call
stoicism and you know something about
everybody else is to be assessed
on that basis and that is
a real danger you don't want to be
assuming
that just because you've had these great
insights that everybody else is having
them
and that they should be measured in
their thoughts and
actions and words and whatever else by
those things
because if you do that you're actually
setting yourself up for a lot
of grief and heartache and
misunderstandings
epictetus actually tells you that when
you start out don't tell anybody that
you're a stoic don't tell anybody here
that you're doing philosophy
just practice it keep working on it and
then after a while if people
ask you hey why do you seem not to lose
your temper so badly
that you can tell them right i've been
practicing stoicism and
it's been helping out i would say even
further don't try to evangelize
meaning don't spread the good news of
stoicism until you've got a solid basis
with it people get very excited and then
they
start telling everybody else how they
ought to behave which is really not a
stoic way instead focus on yourself
develop your own resources turn your
attention to what epictetus calls your
faculty of choice or prior racist you're
ruling faculty
work on improving that start start using
the things that you're learning in the
understanding side
to practice stoicism which then is going
to have a sort of feedback
and teach you more about those ideas
you want to develop something that we
call attentiveness the
ancient greek word for that is prosoque
we're paying attention
not in a morbid or obsessive way but in
a way that's going to be helpful for us
to what our thoughts are to what our
reactions are
to what we do and whether it aligns with
the values that we're
supposedly taking on the other things
that i'll say and here i'm gonna
cut it very short realize that stoicism
is not a set of simple disconnected
ideas it is a systematic and complex
philosophy
that is why people have found it so
powerful
and why it has been around for millennia
it was not developed
as just a bunch of things that can be
plugged in as components
and and you know done at sort of in any
sort of
way willy-nilly no it's done in a more
and more systematic way
if you aren't doing it that way at the
start that's okay
you don't have to but as your practice
gets better and better and your
understanding improves
you're going to want to do that
stoicism is experimental and
experiential
and so you want to be thoughtful about
the things that you're doing
if they didn't work maybe be thoughtful
about why they didn't work they've
worked for so many other people
in the past why didn't they work for you
well that's where we engage
in some mindfulness and some analysis
and we use the things that we understand
to try to
change our practice the very last thing
that i'll say
is once you decide i want to be a stoic
it's going to be something where you
make a resolution and you're going to
fail on that resolution
and you pick yourself up and get back on
the proverbial horse
and that is not just okay that is
the normal way things work nobody
becomes a stoic overnight
as a matter of fact many of us would not
you know even say
i'm i'm a stoic in the sense of being a
fully finished stoic
we would say i'm somebody who's making
progress a proficientes
in in latin or a procopton
in greek and that's the way that many
classic stoics describe themselves
as you're going to find when you start
reading them
so hopefully that is helpful for
people who are asking that very same
question
you